22 chacun
que si je gagne ce sera une personne du
public qui présentera le 6 à 7 demain
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à vous aussi
[Applaudissements]
on dirait la tour de Pise
tellement à l'aise c'est beau
attention
excès de confiance
[Applaudissements]
vous le savez au bout de 5 canettes la
main passe et donc c'est à toi de mettre
la 6
[Applaudissements]
article 11 du règlement et sa switch
s'il te plaît tu peux amener le
règlement s'il te plaît
par contre la tienne est dégueulasse
alors je propose qu'on est à mettre en
même temps je propose que tu la mettes
surtout toi non non j'ai jamais rien mis
n'importe où donc
bravo Siri allez bébé
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite
vous êtes témoin de cette tricherie
tout de suite malheureusement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une fois de plus c'était les spectateurs
de cette émission se disent le bien
encore très
le bien encore triompher sur le mal et
oui les chéris pas toujours je n'ai pas
soufflé vous avez soufflé je n'ai pas
soufflé pas bien j'avais un
taquet Gardie
j'ai eu un petit peu
et voilà c'est parti Castaldi donc
demain bien sûr vous animez le 607 avec
une personne du public ça va mon Roger
très bien motion une personne du public
on va la choisir une fois de plus
[Applaudissements]
attention qui veut me canette une petite
canette tu veux une petite canette
Johnny Depp
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas le pirate des caraïbes c'est
Pirates des Caraïbes c'est juste merci
merci mon chéri
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tiens ma chérie
là je prends un risque
[Rires]
[Musique]
il me reste
Ahmed
je vais
lancer les canettes à tout le public si
aucune des canettes ne tombe par terre
j'en verrai tout le public en weekend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est-ce que vous êtes prêts
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous voulez aller dans un
voyage que je n'ai pas pour l'instant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la pression d'eau qui fait tomber la
canette
tombé canette
on va démarrer ici pression attention
vous êtes prêts
voilà
oh là là il y a pas 36 chaussures est-ce
que les mecs alors où vous décidez de
l'éliminer vous avez perdu le voyage
de l'éliminer vous vous lever
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous avez le droit à trois cockers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
un spectacle de tigre
ah ouais c'est
[Applaudissements]
la famille addisheim
[Musique]
c'est un vrai lanceur de couteau
[Applaudissements]
elle se balade il se balade
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a un peu d'avenir
[Musique]
je vous fais la valise
pour une canette
[Applaudissements]
un assistant
on avait trois chances il reste
exactement
une seule erreur
ce que vous êtes prêts
[Applaudissements]
une canette elle est contente avec ce
ballon il se balade
en bleu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
silence si les téléspectateurs nous
rejoignent nous aurons au jeu de la
canette
des canettes des personnes
il y a un lanceur de canettes de père en
fils
[Rires]
il faut dire à la dame que c'est pas
grave elle a les larmes aux yeux c'est
pas grave
[Applaudissements]
c'est très grave c'est pas grave
vous pouvez y aller madame vous êtes en
train de [ __ ] dans la merde
[Rires]
je ne mens pas au public je suis désolé
je peux tout faire mais je ne mentirai
jamais au public voilà donc elle peut
chialer
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on est lundi
et les règles de la canette sont claires
pour les 5 dernières canettes ce sera
que du quatrièmement que des gens qui
ont payé
[Rires]
c'est le poulet Castaldi tu peux y aller
attention c'est la dernière canette
simple on va démarrer doucement qui la
veut
plus
de responsabilité et voilà
[Applaudissements]
le public
arrive à prendre ses 5 canettes
le public ira passer un séjour quelque
part
[Musique]
Cyril
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
salut
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je vous le dis je terminerai le jeu de
la canette par toi
[Applaudissements]
mon cousin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais te demander de bien vouloir
venir me rejoindre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la pression c'est pas possible
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu étais mon cousin
tu étais plus que la famille
tu étais quelqu'un que je portais dans
mon cœur
et aujourd'hui
tu as assombril destin
de la France entière
quel est ton prénom
pirate tu resteras
de TPMP
on se rappellera
de pirates
et on dira même ici qu'on ne me jette
pas la pirate
GES
tu avais des mocassins magnifiques
tu es venu avec qui
avec qui Céline d'accord
[Rires]
qui sont ces personnes
qui sont ces personnes c'est un ami un
ami
et un ami
bonsoir madame bonsoir triste nouvelle
[Rires]
comment tu te sens
ça va est-ce que tu peux venir
aujourd'hui que tu n'as rien à [ __ ]
ah c'est vrai
j'ai l'impression qu'à la manière de
filmer tu gardes le sourire tu t'en fous
total non tu peux le dire en public
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est toi qui va dans le weekend
[Applaudissements]
car ici même l'échec est récompensé
aux autres personnes qui ont loupé de se
lever
madame
vous partez pour un séjour
partez pour un séjour pour un weekend
avec la personne de votre choix
[Applaudissements]
et pour les autres personnes du public
car je les aime et qu'elles ont fait un
travail exceptionnel je leur offre à
chacune des personnes ici car je les
aime et je trouve que vous avez fait un
travail formidable vous pouvez remercier
les perdants qui partiront en weekend
sachez que je vous offre à chacun une
canette dédicacée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce sera pour vous c'est mon cadeau
et ça c'est comme ça que vous acceptez
mon cadeau ça me fait mal
j'ai tout donné pour vous
les seuls responsables sont les trois
qui vont partir en vacances pourquoi je
les envoie en vacances
ils soient loin de vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu te fous de la gueule de qui
personne donc ce sont des amis à toi
mais tu les amèneras pas en vacances
c'est qu'une personne laquelle vas-tu
choisir parmi les deux Céline d'accord
l'autre non j'ai l'impression que tu ne
l'aimes pas
j'ai l'impression que ça me donne comme
ça ah non mais c'est vraiment que je
suis en dehors de votre histoire je
crois que j'ai l'impression que tu
n'apprécies pas cette personne qui est
en marinière c'est 16e moi aussi c'est
vrai tu
pars en vacances tu as envie de partir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis un artiste chanteur de canette
depuis 1902 de père en fils et elle
croit que je t'emmène dans une agence de
voyage où tu as envie de partir toi
d'accord merci et toi ma chérie
toi tu es au bout de ta vie
faut que tu remontes ma belle
c'est la plus gentille c'est quoi ton
prénom
Candice et toi
qui ça direct
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je sais pas
tu as choisi
[Applaudissements]
merci merci mon chéri
tu peux me rendre à la canette
est-ce que tu peux pas tout gagner non
plus
[Applaudissements]